[Musique]
bonsoir à tous à moins d'une semaine
maintenant de l'ouverture du salon de
l'agriculture sujet c'est délicat et
difficile en ce moment nous recevons le
ministre en charge du sujet bonsoir
desdits guillaume bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous donc merci d'avoir
répondu présent à ce rendez-vous de des
chaînes parlementaires public sénat lcp
assemblée nationale la fp et le figaro
avec moi dans la première partie de
l'émission yves thréard et paul briat
bonsoir messieurs tout à l'heure les
journalistes au rayonnement de chiny
brigitte boucher et puis deux
parlementaires qui feront leur entrée
sur ce plateau dans une vingtaine de
minutes pour vous interpeller ce sont le
sénateur alain houpert sénateur et l'air
que vous connaissez bien de la côte d'or
et puis la députée mathilde de panneaux
député la france insoumises du val de
marne
d'abord donc bien sûr la crise sociale
le mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune
didier guillaume antisémitisme violences
répétées économie locale dévasté ce que
vous dites maintenant ça suffit
non mais ce que je dis surtout c'est que
lorsqu'on voit ces flot de haine
lorsqu'on voit cet antisémitisme
lorsqu'on voit ces images de la
télévision
finkielkraut qui se fait insulter
lorsqu'on voit tout ce qui s'est passé
les quenelles et se dit mais oui ça
suffit c'est pas ça la république ce
n'est pas ça la france des lumières la
france de la révolution française et je
crois vraiment maintenant il faut que
les démocrates les républicains les
femmes et les hommes de ce pays disent
stop
oui il y a des soucis oui il ya des
problèmes oui les problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat des problèmes sociaux évidemment
mais aujourd'hui le mouvement que nous
avons dans les rues ce n'est plus les
gilet jaune du 17 novembre et d'autres
ses doigts va plus du tout sûr manque si
il ya eu il ya aussi dans l'est dans les
manifestations les
les quelques milliers de personnes qui
sont des gens qui sont plus le début et
qui ont toujours ce mais ce sentiment
mais aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui a pris le
dessus demain il ya les et l'extrême
droite et l'extrême gauche fond c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer c'est
c'est d'un côté d'un côté l'islamo
gauchisme que le clan voix et de l'autre
côté la droite ultra la droite et isme
qui s'est manifesté ce week-end mais qui
se manifeste depuis très longtemps
depuis longtemps dans le mouvement des
gilet jaune
c'est un antisémitisme que vous
attribuez que vous imputez notamment à
l'ultra gauche ultra gauche et nutra
droit à ce qu'a dit alain finkielkraut
hier moi je voulais avec des confusions
fait entre enfin des confusions nom et
un discours antisioniste antisémite
vindicatif vis-à-vis évidemment des
juifs des français juifs parce que ils
ont le parti pris évidemment d'israël
non mais dans ce pays aujourd'hui on
constate depuis quelque temps qu'il ya
du racisme de la xénophobie
l'antisémitisme de l'homophobie
tout cela tous la fin de barrage entre
assez vite c'est tout cela que nous
voyons aux jouets et c'est cet
antisémitisme aujourd'hui des profondes
dans la société pas que pas
qu'aujourd'hui
regardez s'était passé pour ilan halimi
et et d'autre c'est terrible ce qui est
en train de se passer nous ne pouvons
pas le tolérer pas l'accepter c'est pour
ça que demain je serai à la
manifestation avec vous je serai dans
une vingtaine de ministres il y aura le
premier ministre oui mais y'aura pas le
président est-ce que ce n'était pas sa
place demain avec le gouvernement je ne
sais pas si le président laissera audi
sera pas non mais parce que le président
ne répond pas à l'appel des partis
politiques en soient mitterrand ya
trente ans où il s'était rendu le
lendemain il ya le dîner du crif est
l'occasion de dire des choses je crois
qu emmanuel macron n'a pas attendu cela
pour s'exprimer pour le poursuivre sur
ses convictions pour la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme contre le racisme en
général quand accident juste n'y a pas
de problème là-dessus précisément
monsieur le ministre il ya des
dispositions qui peuvent être annoncées
à l'occasion du discours du président de
la république
la classe politique le personnel
politique demande notamment deux choses
concret finalise ou pénalise
l'antisionisme au même titre que l'anti
sémitisme vous êtes d'accord avec ça m'a
donné la classe politique pour moi ça
n'existe pas il ya pas la classe prière
et de vandières d'accord il ya eu des
demandes de responsables de responsables
politiques cheveux blancs rires ce matin
disait pourquoi pas mais moi je ne peux
pas vous répondre je peux pas répondre à
cette question
la transition franchement titre étions
trop compliqué on va pas tomber dans le
symbolisme qu'avec moi je pense qu'il ya
une loi aujourd'hui qui condamne les
propos injurieux des propos racistes les
propos qui dénigrent les gens et cela 81
je pense que oui je pense que cette
question c'était justement de sortir les
propos antisémites de la loi de 1881
pour en faire un délit de droit commun
ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui à la télé
ce que l'on voit ce ce flot de haine
c'est un délice absolument insupportable
donc est-ce qu'il va falloir encore
passer par la loi
je danse rien vous savez si chaque fois
qu'il voit là c'est pas de la mission là
mais évidemment la marche est une chose
oui c'est derrière la marche c'est une
chose c'est pour se dire il y avait
samedi
quelques milliers de personnes à paris
et 4000 5000 6000 je sais les
républicains les femmes et les hommes
quoi qu'ils pensent peut-être que
d'ailleurs dans le dans la marche il y
aura des gens qui se revendique une
réponse résister qui est d'aider gilet
jaune
mais voilà mais où jackman pour une
réponse de six axes rd réponse
législative à chaque et événements s'il
doit ainsi la dce fin de la discussion
qui va avoir doit sortir une loi evin
nous verrons bien ce qui se passera pas
l'ouvrir les réponses doivent pas être
uniquement comme cela par rapport à ces
débordements notamment qu'on voit
désormais quasiment chaque samedi est ce
que vous vous dites il faut interdire
les manifestations samedi tels que
d'aucuns proposent jusqu'au bout dit ça
suffit
alors moi jadis interdits mais par
principe par principe parce que je suis
un républicain qui attachés au droit
je ne suis pas favorable à
l'interdiction des manifestations mais
il ya des moyens quand et où l'état
d'urgence a dit ça suffit je reviens à
jo il faut qu'une prise de conscience il
faut peut-être que ce qui ce que ceux
qui se revendiquent comme les leaders du
mouvement gilet jaune puisse dire des
shows et bien qu'après la bride
vous dit le leader sauf qu'il ya des
gens sur les plateaux télé qui parlent
régulièrement et moi je demande à ces
gens là enfin je demande je n'ai pas à
leur demander d'ailleurs mais je pense
qu'il devrait s'exprimer clairement
parce que je ne veux pas faire
l'amalgamé entre le mouvement des gilet
jaune les gens que je connais qui
sentent mal et ce flot de enzo torrent
le malin et d'antisémitisme face à cette
impensable dans la république il y a eu
une autre polémique que depuis ce
week-end dans la façon qu'ont eu
certains de condamner l'agression dont a
été victime alain finkielkraut certains
ont dit oui mais d'autres ont évoqué la
manipulation de l'antisémitisme comment
est-ce que vous réagissez également à ce
point sachant que par exemple jean luc
mélenchon a été critiqué pour une
réaction qui était jugé par certains en
big où elle était ambiguë il n'y a pas
de oui mais dans aucun domaine il n'ya
pas de oui mais je me fiche de qui est
concerné voltaire avait dit je ne suis
pas d'accord avec ce que vous dites mais
je me battrai jusqu'au bout pour que
vous puissiez de dire moi je me fiche
d'untel ou d'untel n'y a pas de oui mais
qu'est ce que l'on doit condamner
purement et simplement au cimt à l'entv
eminem et ben c'est honteux
si on te j'ai lu sur twitter j'ai lu des
grands prix d'un dans tous les domaines
politiques journalistiques citoyens des
gens qui disent oui mais la vie disent
non je veux même pas bon rester que deux
ans est ce que vous regrettez que demain
le front national n'est pas été invitée
jeunes à la verrerie je ne regrette pas
qu'il n'ait pas été invitée moi je suis
membre du gouvernement je vais pas
prendre la place des partis au service
des patrons politiques s'est pas lâché
le patron du ps qui est qu'est lancé
c'est cela tous les partis dits
républicains sont là aujourd'hui très
bien il y aura peut-être des militants
des électeurs du front national a marre
je n'en sais rien mais aujourd'hui force
est de constater que l'extrême droite
française a été souvent ambiguës sur le
sujet d'antisémite et sur
l'antisémitisme il ya des ambiguïtés à
l'extrême gauche à la france insoumise
et à l'extrême droite
je dis qui je dis qu'il existe dans ce
pays là non soumise elle participe
demain on rase en 2000 et bribes et tant
mieux
c'est très bien est ce qu'ils les
anglais et militants les militants de la
france insoumise sont des républicains
sont des mitrailles plus qhd auquel
tablettes du milan
il existe dans ce pays à la fois à
l'extrême gauche
un islam au gauchisme et à l'extrême
droite une sorte de néo nazisme ou
autres qui pointent toujours du doigt
les juifs étaient tous là et qui sont
internes au rassemblement national et à
la française je n'en sais rien je dis
que ça existe parce que la république
est mise en péril aujourd'hui par la
montée aux extrêmes
non la république n'est pas mise en
péril à lui dit qu'elle est forte et les
résiliente ce qui est mis en péril
c'est notre vivre ensemble c'est comment
demain allons nous pouvoir nous
retrouver
c'est pas la république du tout c'est
les citoyens et c'est pour ça que moi
j'en appelle à la fois à la résistance
face à tout cela mais à l'apaisement il
faut de l'apaisement
on ne peut pas continuer comme cela on
pas continuer dans cette violence on
peut pas continuer comme ça et c'est
pour ça oui c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui seul il faut que les uns
et les autres prennent leur
responsabilité tous les partis
politiques y compris ceux qui sont qui
disent à droite comme à gauche qui vont
être là demain et c'est tant mieux et je
n'ai vraiment je fais aucune différence
des autres mais peut-être qu'après il
faudrait que tout le monde condamne sans
réserve cela et 10 bon maintenant il ya
le grand débat il ya je crois 800000
contribution 6000 réunion il y en a
encore 4000 qui doivent se se tenir
barba on va voir la sortie de ce grand
débat c'est de ça dont il s'agit
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
où tous les samedis world dimanche
maintenant on a des images de de haine
la taxe sur le fourgon de police la
jeune femme madame vavasseur qui se fait
extraire levasseur se fait extraire
parce qu'on la reconnaît plus comme
qu'est ce que c'est cette histoire ce
sont ces gens mais je mais qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent nous causer de monsieur
concrètement puisqu'on était dans les
mesures concrètes mais vous dites que ça
passe pas par une réponse législative
néanmoins les réseaux sociaux un peu et
aux yeux de beaucoup contribué à
exacerber cette violence verbale et
montout paraît ce qui faut lever
l'anonymat sur les réseaux sociaux bien
sûr à a mais bien sûr alors la mauricie
très favorable aujourd'hui les réseaux
sociaux ont pris une place terrible dans
notre société
et puis il ya tout un tas de faux
comptes de troll etc où il se dit tout
et n'importe quoi où il a des fêtes news
où on apprend ce n'est pas possible
ce n'est pas ça c'est là où je vous
disais que la république elle est forte
elle n'est pas en péril mais que notre
vivre ensemble les caisses que ce
histoire où il ya 80 ou 90 députés qui
ont été agressés chez eux leurs
permanences abîmé une voiture brûlée ou
on est insulté mais ce n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas possible
reprenons nous françaises et français
reprenons nous regardons pour la levée
donner une loi sur les réseaux sociaux
oui oui je pense je serai bien nous
parler du grand débat il arrive à son
terme dans un mois on est à peu près à
michelin où est ce qu'on va avec ce
grand débat vous vous aviez dit vous
êtes favorable à un référendum ou
journée européenne d'ailleurs fin mai
pour un peu seul mais ce qui serait
ressorti du grand des basques d'abord
c'est sur votre position puisque l'idée
semble abandonnée par exécutif et
comment on fait pour sortir de ce grand
débat et plus largement de cette crise
qu'elle est en novembre là mais il faut
sortir de cette crise comment et à
situation exceptionnelle réponse
exceptionnelle
je pense que cette situation et c'est la
réponse je pense que cette situation est
exceptionnelle
ce qui se passe depuis le mois d'octobre
si quelqu'un me dit qu'il avait prévu ça
non donc on ne peut pas et on ne pourra
pas en sortir par des bouts de
réformettes par des bouts de réponse
donc toujours un référent il faudra que
la réponse soit forte mais vous êtes
impatient c'est absolument pas attendre
oui oui il faut il vous dit que ça lui a
plu il faudra que l'ars bon et là il ya
encore un mois alors mais la même plate
2-2 alors fait c'est quoi cette histoire
mais de bon je suis désolé de vous dire
dénoncer les violences dans l'est mais
il ne prépare le gouvernement n'arrive
pas à les stopper il ne faut pas non
plus que vous vous utilisiez excusez moi
non le débat non mais ça va pas si vite
ça va pas si vite il il a été dit que le
débat se poursuive et jusqu'au 15 mars
laissant se poursuivre les vaches que tu
as tendance à 800000 yves thréard 800000
personnes ne leur ai jamais cru
6000 réunion moi non plus dans ce cadre
un succès donc il faut haïr sortir en
ressortir mon avis par deux ou trois
choses différentes à l'esprit quand on
vous écoute des deux ou trois choses
incroyables allez-y la première chose je
pense qu' il faudra redonner la parole
au peuple
et c'est pour ça que une des réponses ça
sera d'interroger les français je sais
pas sur quoi c'est pas de censure c'est
celui c'est celui du président de la
république ce n'est pas de ma
responsabilité je vais pas en dire plus
je pense que il faudra quelqu'un à
partir du moment où les citoyens sont
exprimées pendant trois mois la
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale la
dissolution
oui mais tout ça sur le terrain à oui
oui non mais bien sûr qu'on est là aussi
non je suis primé dans référendum
redknapp référendum pas forcément le 26
puisque votre idée enfin celle que non
mais défendue je pense qu'il faudra il
faudra le faire vite mais c'est une des
réponses avant l'accord deuxième une des
réponses avant l'été la première est là
la réponse est essentielle
ça sera la prise en compte par le
président de la république de ce qu'il
aura entendu lui-même dans les grands
débats et de ski et de ce qu'il aura vu
et puis il ya une troisième réponse qui
sera la réponse législative
il faudra que l'assemblée nationale
sénat qui elles mêmes vont débattre
peut-être vote sur des lois donc il ya
il ya trois grands de syrie de choses
plus d'avoir plus quand même moi j'en
vois trois grandes comme cela puis après
les choses c'est que je veux dire par là
un oui c'est que nous sommes dans une
démocratie représentative contesté quand
il veut oui mais d'accord mais contesté
par une minorité
oui et qui grand prix contesté par ceux
qui attaquent fit quelques routes ou les
véhicules de police démocratie
représentative tête des élections
peut-être certains nous disent qu'ils pu
garder des paramilitaires qui peut y
avoir autre chose c'est les élections
emmanuel macron est élu pour cinq ans il
remettra son mandat en jeu en 2022
si en 2022 une majorité de français qui
n'en veulent plus il va trouver convions
donc démocratie représentative c'est
quand même à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat de faire la loi mais ça ne suffit
pas et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous dis qu'il faudra aussi consulter
des français sur quoi pressé trait le
plus près possible avant ou après l'été
peu importe mais là là dans les mois qui
viennent on n'est pas là on n'est pas à
trois semaines près ou un mois près la
prestation mais non mais attendez
peut-être d'ici là il y en aura - toute
façon je ne crois pas que s'il devait y
avoir un référendum c'est pas ça qui
arrêtera les manifestations alors qu'ils
arrêtera c'est la réponse d'ampleur
non mais je pense pas qu'il faille
sourire de ça parce que les spéciales
sur la situation est très grave
si une réponse d'ampleur qu'il faudra
qu'il faudra apporter et je pense que le
président de la république l'apportera
et puis il faudra sans aucun doute
changer notre façon de gérer ce pays de
faire de la politique parce que il
faudra sûrement interrogé plus
fréquemment comme nous l'avons fait sur
l'album mobilité interrogé plus
fréquemment
les français qu'ils puissent donner leur
avis sur les lois qu'ils puissent amendé
bon voilà c'est tout cela dont il va
falloir autant vous avez fondé états
généraux depuis que monsieur macron est
aux affaires
les états généraux dans tous les
secteurs se sont multipliés et c'était
une façon aussi d'écouter et de brume et
sa patience à grand chose alors
mais pourquoi vous dites ça va je ne
sais pas parce que cela soit des
personnes à part tout d'abord mais
personne n'avait vu venir ce mouvement
ce moment il part de loin et il part de
près il part de très loin parce que ça
fait 20 ans qu'il est à semble
difficulté il part de près parce qu
emmanuel macron gagne l'élection
présidentielle fait turbuler le système
et les gens veulent encore plus est ce
que je peux et je peux comprendre des
revendications mais il faut aller dans
cette direction il faut être populaire
sans être populiste il faut pas faire de
la démagogie et voie de la démocratie
c'est ça les sujets sur lesquels nous
devons travailler le brillant ce
référendum qu'est ce qu'on met dedans
est ce qu'on met des questions
uniquement constitutionnel ou est-ce
qu'on innove et on met des questions
d'ordre législatives en demandant oui ou
non au peuple kurde et moi je vais pas
répondre à cette question au roi mais je
vais vous répondre je devrais à celle là
la question parce que ce n'est pas de
mon ressort
donc on va pas faire le débat sur le
référendum non mais excusez moi je pense
votre question est très importante mais
je pense que ça n'a aucun sens de faire
le débat sur le référendum
aujourd'hui le peuple à la parole les
débats s'enchaînent les contributions
sur la plateforme du grand débat en
lieux plus de 800 milles il va falloir
attendre la compilation le président de
la république fait des débats j'en ai
fait moi même dans les ca lincoln nous
en france on a la culture jean fait la
loi oui bien sûr tous les soirs il y
aura un débat au salon avec sur des
thèmes différents avec les gens qui se
casse le bouddhisme gilet jaune pour pas
qu'ils viennent manifester bruyamment
perturbé le salon de l'agriculture mais
moi je ne dis rien jugé les jaunes
les gilet jaune qu'est ce que vous avez
fait reprennent prennent leur
responsabilité je ne suis pas encore
organisé par tous les acteurs du salon
de l'agriculture il ya là les forces de
l'ordre la préfecture de police et puis
l'ambiance aînés canada les gars nature
du bien
un paradoxe ces dernières semaines
puisque ce qui vient quand même en tête
c'est d'abord des demandes de pouvoir
d'achat puisque de référendum sur les
institutions et puis il ya un ras-le-bol
fisc alors on a entendu des ministres
lancé le concours lépine la des impôts
vous n'avez pas d'impôts nouveaux a
proposé non moi je ne lance pas de
concours lépine je pense qu'il y avait
les propos je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
choses vraies
la première c'est qu'il ya une coupure
très forte entre paris et la province
entre les élites et le peuple et il ya
une coupure très forte entre moi je suis
là celui qui a qui gagnent plus d'argent
que moi c'est pas bien et celui qui est
moins d'argent que moi il est troupe
aidées par l'état c'est un peu ça
l'histoire
donc je pense qu'il ya dans tout cela
c'est parti quand même sur le pouvoir
d'achat et notamment le poids de la zone
rurale et je pense qu'il faut prêter une
attention particulière à la ruralité qui
parfois se sent un peu délaissé les gens
place publique les gens de la ville aime
bien aller passer leur week end leurs
vacances en zone rurale mais les
services publics sont conquis télé les
zones vertes où il ya quand même une
réalité c'est que les classes moyennes
les classes moyennes ont été les vaches
à lait de la république ces dix
dernières années
parce que la catégorie de français et de
france ont connu des augmentations
d'impôts sous nicolas sarkozy et sous
entreprendre ce sont les classes
moyennes
sous nicolas sarkozy la crosse non non
non pas du tout je n'oublie pas du tout
sous parce que ce n'est pas le cas donc
je peux pas l'oublier
ce n'est pas qu'un nom c'est à dire le
grand bureau c'était donc non mais je
suis désolé il traîna on parle d'un pot
le nommer on parle d'impôts et de taxes
je crois aussi vous rajoutez détails sur
les impôts
nicolas sarkozy a baissé l'ieseg et
baisser les tranches supérieures
françois hollande a augmenté et rend les
tranches supérieures à baisser ou les
classes populaires et les classes
moyennes paient trop d'impôts dans ce
pays nous sommes
le pays où il ya le plus d'impôts une
fois que ça des sacoor la dernière
question une question le premier
ministre vendredi a dit qu' il fallait
des contreparties aux allocations
sociales
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
fait partie du lavaux lui mettre ça dans
le débat donc on verra ce qu'il en
sortira à l'arrivée vous y est plutôt
favorable je suis favorable à la
solidarité sans faille avec ceux de nos
concitoyens qui souffrent et notre pacte
et notre pack triple inverse en contre
c'est cela ces gens là ont déjà des
contreparties quand on est au chômage on
obligeait les dents les pointe et on
oublie la chercher du travail secondes
si on vous l ontt si on refuse un
troisième travail on perdre au large des
philippines veut des contre parties
parce que vous dites est là il est en
décalage là c'est maintenant je suis pas
en décalage
il a lancé sa dans le débat est là c'est
d'abord aller le débat merci merci merci
messieurs à l'institution publique
maintenant avec donc les deux
parlementaires dont je vous annoncer la
présence sur ce plateau il arrive
[Musique]
bonsoir ma petit panneau c'est beaucoup
d'être là vous exécutez la france est
soumise du val de marne et merci à la
coupe air vous êtes là vous êtes
sénateur et l'air de la côte d'or une
question d'un internaute qui nous suit
sur le figaro vous avez évoqué didier
guillaume les réseaux sociaux vous
demander la levée de l'anonymat
est-ce que vous avez des critiques à
faire aux médias est ce qu'ils doivent
eux-mêmes faire leur autocritique
pourrait revoir peut-être je ne sais pas
amplifier ou donner la parole à mais moi
je me permets pas de faire vous avez
qu'ils habitent quoi que ce soit gérard
politique posé l'acte et vous posiez la
question sur les réseaux sociaux je
pense que le mieux c'est que chacun
puisse dire c'est ce qu'il a à dire sur
les réseaux sociaux à visage découvert
pas avec des faux quand on tue toute la
boîte et de panneaux c'est à vous moi je
voulais juste revenir sur une partie
précédente qui me paraît extrêmement
importante par rapport à ce qui a été
dit sur la france insoumise et sur jean
luc mélenchon monsieur le ministre vous
disiez qu'il fallait apaiser le débat
mais lorsque l'on créé des antisémites
en plus en accusant la france en soumise
une grande partie des régions d'être
antisémite ce vote ce n'est pas sérieux
ce n'est pas ce que vous avez dit que
nous avions été ambiguë et que nous
pointions les juifs du doigt en ont
jamais mis au défi de savoir quand est
ce qu'un jour nous avons pointé les
juifs du doigt jamais nous avons
toujours tenu le bout antiracistes et le
combat antiraciste et contre
l'antisémitisme de manière très forte et
je ne permettrai à personne de faire
croire que la france insoumise et ambigu
sur cette question et d'ailleurs nous
agissons très concrètement contre ces
mesures là puisque nous avons mis en
place une commission d' enquête contre
les groupuscules d'extrême droite qui
jusqu'à maintenant sont quand même ceux
qui pratiquent le plus anti c'est la
réponse de diffusion puisque je rappelle
quand même que vous avez effectivement
dénoncé l'ultra droite et l'extrême
gauche
oui je connais la dialectique de
l'extrême gauche et de la france est
soumise par coeur d'amples et c'est pas
le sujet mais simplement ça la façon
dont vous réagissez madame panneaux je
n'ai jamais mis en cause vous pourrez
réécouter l'émission la france insoumise
je pars maintenant j'ai dit l'extrême
gauche et l'extrême droite et je lui dis
qu'il ne faut pas il a été remis qu il
allait parler mais condamnant les
vieilles mais c'est très bien mais ça en
refusant que ça me va très bien
et la majorité des gilet jaune soit
assimilé
anti ce n'est pas le cas je le crois
même l'avoir précédé tout à l'heure
jamais dit cela mais y'a pas de problème
là que c'est être un mot déjà sur le
banc situation sociale telle que nous la
vivons
la france est en crise mais je voudrais
sortir par le haut didier guillaume et
moi même nous connaissons bien nous
sommes d'un côté de l'hémicycle de
chaque côté mais nous nous apprécions je
suis très heureux que tous les deux vous
connaissez très bien la ruralité
mélenchon rituellement monaco comme nous
le voyons donc ce matin on a connu en
tant que senior du groupe
j'étais pas là encore il était alors l
on l'a croisé dans tous les cas je je
voudrais je suis heureux qu'ils soient
ministres de l'agriculture puisque c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît bien la ruralité
c'est quelqu'un qu'il a travaillé
pendant plusieurs années et je voudrais
revenir un petit peu à ce que vous avez
dit monsieur le ministre sur les classes
moyennes et les agriculteurs sont
vraiment dans la classe moyenne même
dans la classe moyenne du bas et son
c'est une profession qui souffre au
quotidien avec des suicides et nous
avons pointé en tant que rapporteur
spécial du budget de l'agriculture j'ai
repoussé votre budget il y à des retards
dans l'exécution du paiement des
subventions agricoles des retards dans
l'administration des subventions
publiques européennes la france a
consommé cette année plus de 2 milliards
de son budget national pour compenser ce
retard
où en est on alors il ya eu une
défaillance des du service public et de
l'état sur le paiement des aides venant
de l'europe par ce qu'on appelle la sp
l'autorité de services de paiement nous
sommes en train de rattraper le retard
malheureusement c'est très très longue
j'appelle un chat un chat je vous dis
qu'il ya une défaillance plus ce qui est
des êtres qui devaient être versées en
2016 qui ne sont pas encore totalement
fini de verser notamment les aides les
aides sur le bio est pour pour les
jeunes au printemps les
les aides seront payés pour 2016 et 2017
et 2018 ça sera revenu à la normale
payer cette année en 2019
il ya un vrai retard et moi je le dis
dans tous mes déplacements je demande
bien de vouloir excuser cela pour pour
les gens ça ne s'arrête pas le problème
je veux simplement rappeler kahn que sur
les 4000 yards aides qui sont versés
chaque année aux agriculteurs il y en a
200 millions qui ne sont pas payés il
faut faire la propose ses 200 millions
de trop enfin il y en a 4 milliards et
900 millions qui l'ont qu'ils ont et
qu'ils ont été donc voilà mais c'est je
le regrette
j'ai trouvé cette situation en arrivant
on a essayé d'accélérer les choses de
présent la république uppr ministre de
le faire il ya eu un gros problème
d'engorgement et voilà on bâtit de
panneaux oui monsieur mini ce jeudi
c'est notre niche parlementaire donc
seulement la france insoumise mais ses
propositions à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale et nous déposons
donc une proposition de loi qui propose
l'interdiction du glyphosate où nous
sommes calés sur la promesse
présidentielle donc du 27 novembre 2020
quel avis le gouvernement va-t-il donner
à cette proposition de loi mais nous
partageons le même la même volonté
apparemment celle d'arrêter glyphosate
donc
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire vadam plano
les 27 novembre 2001 3 à 0 % glyphosate
en france ces cinq ans est entré en jeu
ce que je veux vous dire c'est que moi
je ne fais pas de politique politicienne
et je ne mens pas aux agriculteurs parce
que je les connais bien je vais vous
répondre
c'est ce gouvernement et pas un autre
qui a interdit le glyphosate et le round
up pour les privés là c'est ce
gouvernement et pas un autre qui
interdit l'utilisation du glyphosate et
du round up pour les agriculteurs sur
les terrains dans quelle il va y avoir
des récoltes qui lie à l'alimentation
et c'est ce gouvernement et pas un autre
quand vos amis au parlement européen
vote et tergiverse et vote
l'interdiction du glyphosate
en cinq ans nous nous trouvons que c'est
trop et c'est ce gouvernement qui va
l'arrêter au bout de trois ans
donc voilà c'est la différenciation
écoutez vrai laissez moi finir il ya
ceux qui parlent beaucoup
il ya ceux qui font de la polémique
politicienne il ya ceux qui agissent
mais nous avons toujours dit que
malheureusement c'est l'étude de l'âne
c'est ce qui a été fait il ya deux ans
qui indique que pour une petite partie
des filières agricoles
ce n'est pas possible pourquoi
j'ai été quand j'étais sénateur opposé
je crois d'ailleurs comme alain houpert
d'interdits de mettre la tradition du
glyphosate dans la loi pourquoi parce
que ça aurait été une erreur
phénoménal ce qu'ils voulaient mettre
l'interdiction de glyphosate dans la loi
c'est est ce qu'elle est condamnée à
mort une partie de l'agriculture
française vous voulez peut-être en faire
cela c'est vous les 7 faire cela moi je
vous dise la langue c'est cela c'est ce
qu'a indiqué donc la france sera le
premier pays en europe est le premier
pays au monde à interdire le glyphosate
c'est pas sérieux sur une chose reçu non
c'est pas sérieux à base sur ce que le
peuple lorsque le président de la
république sans une promesse pour dire
que c'est le 27 novembre 2020
ce que nous mettons dans nos
propositions de loi et que vous arrivez
comme ministres effectivement en disant
oui non mais vous avez dit 1er janvier
en disant 80% des usages puis peut-être
50 % des hôtels de congestion je veux
quelque chose d'extrêmement flou laissé
ses fournisseurs
nous sommes devant des agriculteurs dont
un agriculteur sur 5 souffrent de
maladies liées à l'usagé des pesticides
nous sommes face à une situation où les
oiseaux les insectes moi je ne vous
apprends rien les abeilles sont en train
de mourir de manière massive
nous sommes devant une situation où tous
les français à 100 % sont contaminés par
ce glyphe hosatte et rappelez-vous du
chlordécone le chlordécone c'est
exactement la même situation c'est à
dire que la france autorise en 1972 les
états il interdit en 1976 justement
parce qu'on savait on est aux antilles
et ses laboratoires d'analysé vous savez
tout le monde savait exactement comme le
glyphosate que ça tu es donc on donne
des permis de tuer aux entreprises et
alors qu'est ce qui est drôle pour le
chlordécone sécu en 1990 quand on dit ah
non finalement faut l'interdire
la controverse scientifique ont permis
encore trois ans mais qui tourne un peu
donc nous ce que nous demandons c'est
que la décision soit prise maintenant
qu'elle soit effectivement inscrits dans
la loi pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
mensonges et de cette news com vous
disais vous disiez tout à l'heure
ben non moi je suis opposé à ce qu'on
met ça dans la loi maintenant les
députés européens
de vos amis comme de tous ont voté aux
premiers germes et 2023
nous nous disons ce 1er janvier 2021
pour une immense partie est d'ailleurs
moi je travaille sur les plantes filière
l'agroécologie moi j'étais le président
d'un département dont j'ai fait le
premier département bio de france
syndrome 50 % des repas dans la
restauration scolaire sont elles sont
bio donc j'ai aucun problème
est ce que vous dites la transition et
agro écologiques j'en fais l'alpha et
l'oméga de la politique agricole de ce
ministère l'alfa c'est exactement ce que
j'ai lancé les transitions bio un
milliard cent millions pour le bio 71
millions d'euros avec madame vidal pour
la recherche pour les pour les
alternatives l'ansès j'ai demandé à
l'ansés autorité indépendante de
vérifier les 150 de mise en marché de
produits sanitaires dans lesquelles
durée du glyphosate pour nous dire
lesquels peuvent être à arrêter dès
maintenant est celle dont il n'est pas
possible via pas l'alternative
je travaille sur le biocontrôle je
travaille sur toutes les alternatives je
ne souhaite pas que l'on remplace le
glyphosate est une molécule chimique par
une autre molécule chimique
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
changer les pratiques agricoles mais
s'il doit y avoir une infime partie des
filières agricoles qui ne sont pas
prêtes au 1er janvier 2021
eh ben il y aura un petit décalage
peut-être l'objectif c'est 100 % de non
dépendance aux produits phyto changer de
sujet des alpes a relevé le glyphosate
permet quand même encore une question
sur le glyphosate puisque comme est-ce
que vous réagissez monsieur le ministre
que cette étude qui est dans le monde ce
soir je lui avais qui montre une nette
augmentation du risque de lymphome chez
les professionnels en raison en raison
du glyphosate alors 41 % si je vous
conseille de l'info ou une étude
scientifique et qui est uniquement
américaine dira monsieur vous dit ça
vous ne comprenez moi je suis là pour
protéger la santé des français
oui je suis là pour appliquer le
principe de la le lymphome non mais je
les ai vus ça alors c'est pour ça que la
france sera le premier pays au monde à
interdire aux apps
je peux pas vous dire
daumas et un poster ses pairs je reviens
2021 promis j'espère d'autres sujets
importants et notamment la pac qui va
être réformé avec des conséquences peut
être néfaste sur l'agriculture française
mais cet autre chose
et puis la loi alimentation également
dont on parle beaucoup depuis le début
du mois donc au sénat on est plus calme
le glyphosate il ya quand même une
controverse scientifique il faudra en
sortir et trouver des conclusions il n'y
a pas de controverse scientifique sur
cette question monsieur le sénateur par
quoi commencer vous l'a pas la joie
alimentation claparède et des produits
il va falloir qu'on ait une bonne
négociation qui se fait un peu dans la
douleur
actuellement elle se fera sur quelle
base sachant que que quels sont les
objectifs de développement quels sont
les objectifs de production quels seront
les objectifs pour avoir des prix
abordables et revenir sur ses déficits
de paiement parce que les subventions
européennes par exemple sur le cadre
leader ou fait adhère c'est un gâchis
11%
hans % de consommation actuellement sur
sur le leader ça c'est 100%
responsabilité région je peux assumer
tout bleu
on arrive à une décentralisation
complète et sur la sécurité alimentaire
tout à l'heure il n'y a pas que lui
qu'il faut c'est de la sécurité
alimentaire s'impose des bas et j'ai
fait un rapport sur la sécurité
alimentaire où il ya quand même quelques
problèmes et actuellement on l'a vu avec
la viande roumaine la viande de cheval
maintenant c'est la viande polonaise la
peste porcine et je comprends les gens
que les français se posent des questions
et nous sommes dans l'espace schengen
avec un problème quand même de frontière
où les produits sont contrôlés à
l'entrée de l'europe
et ensuite voilà donc là d'un pays à
l'autre pour se balader un peu
alors oui oui
d'insécurité de la sécurité je dirais
pas l'avis de l'avion leur entrée la
viande qui tenteraient frauduleusement
en france en moins de 72 heures
puissantes les services haut débit 100
kg et quelques à moins de 60 blessés
certes on a tout retrouvé donc les
services de sécurité français sont quand
même très très bon mais justement on
peut contrôler je reprends ce que disait
monsieur on perd on peut contrôler alain
à l'entrée de l'europe mais pas à
l'intérieur c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous créons une force de
sécurité sanitaire qui va être
européenne qui pourra aller enquêter
dans chaque pays c'est indispensable
pour éviter à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne c'est la libre circulation
des marchandises ce qui s'est passé pour
la viande entrés frauduleusement de
pologne elle est entrée frauduleusement
c'est une fraude les entreprises qui ont
acheté cette viande ils sont absolument
pour rien sont pas mises en cause du
tout mais l'étiquettage avait été mal
fait c'est pour ça que deuxièmement j'ai
nous avons obtenu la france obtenue à
demande du présent de la république
encore que l'expérimentation sur
l'étiquetage continue pour qu'on puisse
bien se trouver cela et en moins de 72
heures bravo aux services de sécurité de
notre pays qui ont retrouvé l'ensemble
de la viande on peut être fier de ses
services vous voulez dire que la plus
belle des sécurités c'est raccourcir les
circuits plus des circuits ça me vont
sur plus automatiquement savais même pas
si vous avez quelque chose à dire sur la
réforme de la politique agricole commune
vous dénoncez l'europe aujourd'hui telle
qu'elle est conduite il y aura des
baisses dans la politique agricole quant
à l'objet d'une 15 15% quand même y aura
une baisse de lundi je attend d'être la
pac attendait la commission européenne j
avais proposé un premier budget pour la
prochaine pac qui baisse de 15% à partir
de 2020 ça a été refusé il ya un groupe
de vingt états vont en appeler les
accords de madrid puisque c'est passé à
madrid demain et à qui on dit non donc
aujourd'hui il ya une minorité d une
majorité de blocage pour que le budget
ne baisse pas mais je vais être très
honnête oui le break site donc le
royaume uni s'en va donc forcément il y
aura une baisse du budget de l'europe
donc une baisse du budget de la pac à
due concurrence du départ de du royaume
uni on va pas mentir aux gens mais ce
que nous voulons c'est que en fait en
activité économique politique en
développement ça ne bouge pas et j'ai
mandat du gouvernement du président
république pour me battre et pour donner
l'opposition de la france et une baisse
du budget d'accord mais là je crois que
nous sommes tous d'accord là dessus nous
ce qu'on dit sur la pac et sur l'union
européenne l'union européenne
aujourd'hui ne défend plus les peuples
ont dit on dit que c'est une européenne
union européenne qui défend les gens
mais finalement elle défend les intérêts
des grandes multinationales des plus
riches d'un pays des banquiers mais elle
ne défend plus les peuples et sur la pac
c'est de manière très claire qu'il faut
la réorienter parce que si nous ne la
réorientant pas nous continuons avec ce
modèle agricole productiviste qui est en
train de détruire les possibilités de
survie pour les générations futures qui
fait le désert autour de soi et surtout
qui en ferme les agriculteurs dans un
modèle qui aujourd'hui fait qu'un alain
un paysan ce site tous les deux jours et
que un paysan sur trois vit avec moins
de 350 euros par mois et ça ce n'est
plus possible de continuer avec ce
modèle là alors moi j'aurai je les dis
que j'ai été nommé j'aurai réussi mon
passage au ministère si le jour où je
partirai oui il y aura plus un sujet de
la culture tous les deux jours parce que
c'est insupportable pour ça y est la loi
alimentation on va essayer de faire
remonter les revenus aussi mais je vais
répondre sur la pac pas ce que je fais
je
je partage une grande nation de la
réforme de la pac que nous voulons elle
est très claire c'est une pac totalement
réorienté c'est à dire une pac forte il
faut la garder une pac intégré
européenne s'est pas chaque pays qui
fait sa salade parce que ça pourra pas à
marcher mais nous voulons mettre deux
choses à l'intérieur un la transition
agroécologiques indispensable et pour la
première fois elle va rentrer très
fortement dans la politique agricole
commune je pense que nous aurons une
majorité et deux c'est la protection des
la petite agriculture l'agriculture de
montagne la culture de petites filières
là dessus nous avançons dans la pac va
évoluer maintenant nous avons besoin
malgré tout et je le dis et ça peut être
une différence des berges ans que nous
avons la pax et 9 7 milliards d'êtres
directes aux agriculteurs
bien sûr que les agriculteurs français
comme européen veulent vivre de leurs
revenus pas des aides mais aujourd'hui
si nous baissions les aides directes
alors là nous détruisons la vie plus
mais alors vous avez dit une chose un
instant là vous avez un objectif vous
vous êtes fixé un objectif en terme de
suicide
vous avez jusqu'à fiction c'est
difficile c'est extrêmement délicat bien
se passer mais si mais c'est dramatique
audit donc oui un tous les deux jours et
encore ce matin parce que la question
est taboue
c'est catastrophique est-ce que l'on
peut pas continuer comme ça avant
l'heure les gens qui ont cas
mais pas nous vient de dire qu'ils ont
400 350 400 euros 400 euros par mois qui
n'arrivent pas à vivre de leurs de leur
travail
et puis je vous dire aussi autre chose
quoi qui sont montrés du doigt sans
cesse la ghriba chine comme des
pollueurs comme des empoisonneurs comme
ça c'est pas possible
quand je vous disais tout à l'heure dans
la première partie de l'émission qu'il
faut réconcilier l'urbain et le rural
l'agriculture et la société
l'agriculteur et le citoyen c'est
absolument indispensable mais la pac
elle doit protéger on va nous à nous
travaillons à leur pack qui protège
notre notre agriculture française qui
doit protéger également c'est la loi
alimentation et là où père est ce que
vous estimez que d'après les premières
informations que l'on a c'est concluant
on parlait du suicide des agriculteurs
lisez le merveilleux livre de
houellebecq sérotonine qui illustrent
avec beaucoup de verve et la loi à gris
à gris alim c'est une loi vertueuse pour
donner plus de revenus aux agriculteurs
mais on a vu une augmentation du panier
du caddie du panier consommateurs et il
faudrait qu'on puisse avoir des mesures
coercitives sur la grande distribution
qui ne joue pas son rôle
et concernant la grossesse et quelle
mesure c'est très simple d'abord 18 mois
de discussions entre le monde agricole
la distribution les industriels les
politiques ça ne s'était jamais produit
il a été ces orientations ont été faites
de façon collective
l'objectif c'est d'inverser la
construction du prix l'agriculteur c'est
le seul vendeur d'un produit qui le vend
en dessous de son prix de revient ce
n'est pas acceptable pourquoi ne pas
fixer des prix la passion parce que
parce qu on vit tout simplement d'une
économie qui n'est pas administré en
peut pas le faire c'est pour cela que ce
qui est en train de se passer c'est en
train d'avancer
peut-être pas la première année
l'augmentation du panier moyen avec le
seuil de revente à perte
s'il n'est pas aussi important qu'on
verra comment le pourcentage de hausse 0
7% tout l'étude tout 07 08 60
on les d'autres jeunes à présent vous
savez moi je suis écouté jettent alors
des chaussures je vais vous répondre et
tranquillement si dans le panier tous
les jours vous mettez du nutella du coca
cola du ricard des chips des granola et
des pâtes
si tu avais je connais il ya mille
produits sur 23000 pas réparé
hypermarchés mais par contre pour les
mesures coercitives c'est très simple
combien la dgccrf direction générale
convenance corruption l'impression
d'être aude lance 6000 contrôle 6000
elle avait déjà fait près de 200 c'est
350 mille euros de mémoire pour un
groupe et 75000 euros par magasin
voilà vous avez la réponse ab je sais
pas ça ne dépare pas de moi ça dépend de
bercy et du ministère de l'économie et
des finances mais les contrôles ont lieu
60 c'est 75000 euros par magasin et je
crois trois cent cinquante mille euros
c'est une enseigne
il ya comme un chiffre qui est
intéressant à savoir pour pour les gens
en général gène en moyenne lorsqu'une
personne va dans un supermarché ep 1
euro elle donne 7 centimes aux paysans
et nous nous avions proposé des pipes
des prix plancher parce que oui il
serait possible de faire des prix
plancher dans une économie qu'on
relocalise rit parce que vous êtes dans
un gouvernement qui fait des traités de
libre échange à tout va donc il fait
effectivement venir des marchandises d'
extrêmement loin ce qui en termes
écologiques au moment du promu grand de
quoi parle défi climatique au sûr que
des viandes le ceta par exemple qui est
déjà appliquée alors que l'avenir était
voté ni parler le geste fatal ou non
mais c'est un problème vous rendez
compte qu'il ya un traité de
libre-échange qui est en train d'être
négocié avec l'australie et la nouvelle
zélande sur du lait en mai 2000 en
attendant terminé mais ce que je voulais
je le savais plus juste juste un mot sur
sur cette question là l'incitation ça ne
fonctionne pas et c'est pour ça que je
n'ai pas confiance sur le glyphosate non
plus il faut une fois arrêté densité il
faut contraindre
alors la réponse du ministre la met
aujourd'hui vous dire que tout est
réussi à 100% non moi je tiens le
discours de la vérité je rencontre les
filières tous les jours j'ai rencontré
tous les responsables de la grande
distribution les industriels etc
les choses vont dans le bon sens et nous
avançons aujourd'hui il n'y a jamais eu
autant de contrats qui ont été signés
est-ce que c'est assez haut ce que nous
avons demandé par rapport à ce que dit
matt hill panneaux le prix plancher le
prix plancher on peut pas le mettre en
place par la loi dans le cas d'une
économie
ouverte mais ce que nous avons fait
c'est que chaque filière chaque
interprofessions a mis en place son coût
de production coups en dessous duquel on
ne peut pas acheter le produit
c'est un set c'est en train de se mettre
en place
voilà les négociations sont pas
terminées chez un bilan d'étape merci
exactement il avoir participé à cet
échange merci troisième partie
d'auditions publiques maintenant avec
lauriane mancini et brigitte boucher
comme chaque semaine
[Musique]
2 merci d'être avec nous comme chaque
semaine une question d'un internaute du
figaro qui vous demande monsieur le
ministre comment doper la compétitivité
de nos arboriculteurs par exemple qui
est mise à mal par les charges sociales
il ya un an je l'aï fait que l'or alors
le budget 2010 9 de l'agriculture à une
baisse de charge globale pour la culture
de 100 millions d'euros c'est les plus
grandes baisses et par rapport aux
arboriculteurs qui d'un secteur que je
connais bien parce que dans mon
département de la drôme d'un buteur il a
été mise en place des exonérations pour
les travaux occasionnels pour les
travailleurs saisonniers
je crois que c'est à ça qu'il fait
allusion et et ses 1000 s'est gardé pour
la campagne 2010 9 d'accord pour un prêt
parce qu'effectivement là c'est
allègements de charge des budgets sur
unibet c'est une grosse étude mais très
très mais c'est à nos budgets
oui d'accord bon année après année on
verra brigitte eh oui comme chaque école
chaque fois c'est la loi d'accord la
question des délits au salon de
l'agriculture va s'ouvrir samedi
il ya un moment en ce moment d'agri
bashing de contrer des antispécistes des
pesticides y aller les suicides des
agriculteurs auxquels vous avez fait
référence tout à l'heure est-ce que ce
salon ne souffre pas sous de mauvais
auspices
j'ai plutôt le sentiment que ce salon
s'ouvre sous de bons auspices pourquoi
parce que justement les sujets à les
états généraux de l'alimentation la loi
et galim dont nous parlions avec les
deux intervenants précédents fait que
les choses sont en train de changer
que moi je veux me bagarrer contre
l'avis bashing je vous parlais de
réconciliation il faut le faire et mon
objectif c'est que les agriculteurs
gagnent plus leur vie et tout cela en
mutant il faut que l'agriculture multi
gagne plus c'est en place depuis le 1er
février au matin lui a vu la taille mais
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire cela
il a vu la facture s'alourdir de 0 7%
pour un panier moyen
mais vous aurez remarqué que michaud
d'art de clercq est le seul qui dit cela
puisque aucune des autres responsables
de la grande distribution le 10
puisqu'elles ont toutes signé cette
mesure toutes les enseignes de la grande
distribution à part michel edouard
leclerc
les industries agroalimentaires les
petites entreprises et le monde agricole
ont signé
le relèvement du seuil de revente à
perte c'est quoi le relèvement qui
aurait dû rentrer à perdre c'est tout
simplement de dire on ne peut pas vendre
un produit moins cher que ce qu'on
achète
c'est quand même la moindre des choses
et qu'est ce qui se passait pour ses
produits d'appel c'est tout simplement
que la grande distribution ils se
tiraient la bourre pour attirer le
consommateur et ils vendaient des
produits moins chers que voilà c'est
tout cela on veut pas mais ce qu'on veut
surtout c'est que le revenu de
l'agriculteur monte et qu'ils puissent
vendre leurs produits par les
d'arboriculture leur pêche l'eure l'eure
abricots leur viande le lait je vais
vous citer deux exemples
prenons le lait le litre de lait ça
revient à un éleveur laitier en gros le
coût d'objectif a été mis 39 centimes
jusqu'à maintenant on leur acheter 30 32
centimes et vous l'achetez dans votre
supermarché à 1 euro disent en euros 20
il ya de la marge sur la viande c'est en
gros en leur rendant leur avant leur
achète à 3,090 ça leur revient à 5 euros
et on le trouvait à 15 ou 10 9 euros en
grande surface
excusez moi de vous dire que entre ces
deux ces deux montants il ya la
possibilité de mieux répartir la valeur
c'est tout simplement ce que l'on dit
peut-être que chacun prenne un peu moins
de marge et je pense qu'il faut jouer
sur l'intelligence des françaises et des
français je suis sur les freins et
peut-être oui mais ils vont chercher les
prix les plus bas taux mais je le
comprends mais le problème ce n'est pas
ce que ça coûte c'est ce que ça vaut ces
sectes d'important et je pense que les
français sont capables de dire je peux
payer
peut-être un centime de plus mon litre
de lait si je sais que ça arrive un
centime de plus sûrs tels produisent
chez que ça arrive dans la cour de ferme
et il ya peut-être possibilité puisque a
toujours des dés de faire baisser les
prix de dire peut-être on peut vendre en
grande distribution en magasin un peu
moins pour ça je les recruteurs
l'objectif c'est que de réconcilier le
citoyen et l'aviculteur mais le citoyen
peut être l'auteur et l'adultère peu de
citoyens
en tout cas ils sont tous consommateurs
justement entre transition cette année
au salon est de lutter contre cet
agrégat ching ce dénigrement de
l'agriculture comment vous allez faire
en faisant que du positif parce que moi
je veux montrer je veux que la culture
française montre à aux femmes et aux
hommes aux enfants qui vont venir ce que
c'est bon alors vous allez masquer
certaines réalités
pas du tout je ne masquerait vous avez
remarqué que sur la viande à qui est
entré frauduleusement en france de
pologne
c
et moi qui ai annoncé dès tôt le matin
que c'était là leur personne n'avait
aucun aucune information n'était paru si
la transparence totale
on a demandé aux paysans français après
la seconde guerre mondiale de produire
de produire de produire de mettre des 1
30 m des pesticides
parce qu'il fallait nourrir la france et
l'europe on leur a demandé de faire la
quantité de la quantité et maintenant on
leur dit stop faut faire de la qualité
bon eh bien tout cela ça prend du temps
pour le faire mais il a dit que les
agriculteurs l'ont fait aujourd'hui ans
par exemple on utilise 30 % de moins
d'eau pour irriguer l'aviculture qu'il
ya 15 ans il ya des plans ce qu'on
appelle ecophyto pour baisser les
phytosanitaires qui ont utilisé en place
en baisse des phytosanitaires
il va y avoir la sortie du clip hosatte
nous avons mis en place ce qu'on appelle
des plantes filière jeu pas être trop
technique qui fait dans chaque filière
la filière volaille la filière viande la
filière et cetera et cetera et cetera
eh bien on se fixe des objectifs donc
moi je souhaite que l'on parle
positivement de l'agriculture les
agriculteurs ce ne sont pas des
pollueurs des empoisonneurs simplement
on leur a donné un modèle il faut
changer ce modèle est ce modèle pour
faire muter l'agriculture c'est
l'agroécologie aujourd'hui on a besoin
de capter du carbone et la culture peut
capter du carbone on a besoin de
cultiver différemment on n'est pas
obligé de labour et des sols de les
laisser ouverts toute l'année et où les
taux de l'hiver et ou de laisser seuls
sont vides il faut remettre de la
richesse dans les sols c'est tout cela
et on a beaucoup d'expérience et
beaucoup d'exemples juste pas mettre en
avant pour finir sur le salon emmanuel
macron
inaugurant ce salon samedi matin vous
serez à ses côtés évidemment vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus sur le
programme il va il va arriver le matin
tôt je pense qu'il va faire une
intervention devant des jeunes sur sur
l'europe la culture et l'europe parce
que aujourd'hui l'agriculture et
l'europe c'est consubstantiel nous avons
parlé tout à l'heure de la politique
agricole commune ya beaucoup de choses
qui dépendent de l'europe du libre
échange il faut arriver à cadrer tout
cela nous avons besoin de travailler sur
notre autonomie alimentaire
s'il est indispensable que la france
garde au programme dans le discours du
chef de l'état tué après il y aura ce
qu'on appelle la déambulation donc la
balade dans les devants les dans les
stands
c'est une saison record l'an dernier
pendant ces 12 heures
non alors là oui on peut encore je pense
qu'il faut arrêter cette histoire de
records c'est pas du quantitatif là
aussi qu'il faut faire c'est du
qualitatif cette accueillait les fermes
usines qui se multiplient est ce que
c'est le modèle à suivre
justement face à la concurrence
européenne non cela ferme usine ce n'est
absolument pas le modèle ans à suivre je
suis opposé au serbe usine je n'ai aucun
aucun état d'âme le modèle français
c'est le modèle de la culture familiale
de la culture paysanne s'est on vit sur
une exploitation
notre difficulté c'est de plus en plus
on agrandit les exploitations
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à transmettre
et à faire en sorte que des jeunes
s'installent
parce que avec l'âge moyen des
agriculteurs si les jeunes ne s'installe
pas ça ne fonctionnera pas et pour que
les jeunes s'installent
il faut leur donner envie de s'installer
et pensant que de la grille bashing
c'est pour ça que je n'en unis une une
immense campagne pour expliquer la
formation laventure du vivant c'est
formidable pour un jeune de venir
travailler dans nature dans
l'agriculture dans l'aspect sécuritaire
sanité accédera c'est absolument
formidable dans l'herboristerie dans
dans les plantes à l'avant sont là
dedans
donc il faut vraiment aller dans cette
direction
c'est comme cela que nous arriverons à
gagner dorian et un mot sur les
abattoirs puisque la fondation brigitte
bardot a filmé en caméra cachée à un
abattoir de rodez dans l'aveyron qui
pratiquent l'abattage des bovins sans
étourdissement la vidéo a été publiée ce
matin qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de
ces images
alors il ya deux choses sur les
abattoirs il ya les abattoirs dans leur
ensemble et puis à l'aspect
religieux avec les battages rituel
l'abattage rituel l'abattage rituel
c'était le cas de cas a été évoqué sur
les abattoirs beaucoup de choses ont été
faites notamment dans la loi et galim
avec la possibilité de mettre des
caméras condition que les salariés de
l'abattoir le souhaite il y a deux
vétérinaires par abattoirs qui surveille
la chaîne d'ailleurs ce qu'il a été dit
là c'est qu'il n'est pas de problème si
j'ai bien compris un terme en les termes
les utilitaires depuis cette loi chaque
à chaque salarié de l'abattoir est
lui-même un lanceur d'alerté donc il
peut le dire en étant protégé et une
personne un agent par abattoirs lui à la
responsabilité de d'indiquer s'il y a du
mal être ou de houe de la maltraitance
animale s'attendaient tout ça c'est la
réalité donc il faudra encore aller plus
loin il faut que ce soit mais absolument
nickel moi j'ai pas mis plus d'une
demi-heure à fermer un abattoir dans
l'indre à l'automne parce qu'il y avait
des problèmes je m'éclate et jean
fermerait d'autres sans aucun problème
mais il faut aussi en ouvrir d'autres
à condition qu'ils trouvent que vous
écoutez les lanceurs d'alerté donc oui à
la vie en vous de parler de ceux qui
sont à l'intérieur des abattoirs mais on
a beaucoup à l'extérieur je pense
notamment à l'association l214 on
l'écouté mais moi j'écoute tout le monde
j'écoute tout le monde et vous parliez
de la violence dans les rues de file
dans les rues bardot axa bondit
moi je sais que j'ai de la violence on
le sait devant les abattoirs
voilà moi ce que je n'accepte pas c'est
la violence d'où qu'elle vienne ce que
je n'accepte pas c'est qu'on a et cassé
des vitrines de boucher parce qu'ils
vendent de la viande
ce que je n'accepte pas c'est qu'il faut
un abattoir dans l'impasse que son
abattoir
ce que je n'accepte pas c'est la
violence mais chaque le droit de faire
ce qu'il veut bien moi je respecte tout
le monde s'il ya des gens qui ne
souhaitent pas manger de la viande qui
veulent être weygand vegan qui ne
veulent pas manger de la viande du
poisson c'est l'heure c'est leur droit
moi je n'ai aucun point en 14
ils ont montré des images de chevaux
abattus dans un abattoir du jura c'est
les syndicats agricoles singe sur ce cas
les règles sanitaires et d'abattage ont
été justement respecter est ce que vous
vous dites ce sont des lanceurs d'alerté
ou au contraire est-ce que ce sont des
activistes h l214
les deux mon capitaine je crois que
c'est je crois que c'est un peu les deux
il faut quand même se dire une chose
c'est que si on veut changer de société
sans animaux sans abattoirs et c'est
pour ça c'est une autre chose excusez
moi mais d'abord m'a d'abord une filière
et actuel économique forte
mais quand même des gens qui veulent
manger de la viande mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'un abattoir
c'est pas une nursery c'est pas une
c'est pas une crèche a donc
effectivement il ya des images qui sont
pas bonnes
moi ce que je veux c'est qu'il n'y aucun
dérapage il ya des règles qui
l'empêchent pas de cruauté il ya des
pères des caméras obligatoire c'était
une promesse de campagne
j'allais dire 'est-ce que vous
accepteriez de travail devant une caméra
oui parce que vous faites ça mais non la
recherche
mais oui c'est ça pour que ça brille
malade mais il ya des gens il ya des
gens qui ne sont pas seulement pour
l'instant atteint pour l'instant
pour l'instant c'est optionnel là où il
ya une demande en mettra et je pense
qu'il y aura une nouvelle jurisprudence
qui se mettra en place pour délinquants
aux abattoirs orial repose la question
avec elle n'avait pas répondu me sur
l'abattage sans étourdissement
c'est interdit dans l'union européenne
sauf en france dérogation est ce que
vous avez votre gestuelle alors moi je
ne veux pas entrer dans ce débat là
aujourd'hui parce que je pense que on
est là pour apaiser et que ce n'est pas
d'enjeu saisonnalité c'est une jolie dit
je vous dis que ce sujet sur a pris dans
les mois qui viennent mais je ne
souhaite pas parler à non non non non
mais je ne souhaite pas en parler
aujourd'hui
il faudra il faudra a dit bartoli a
écrit une lettre c'est pas pareil il
faudra il faudra en cliquant oui oui
j'ai vu j'ai vu cette lettre il ya en
tout cas une chose qui est sûre c'est
que dans les semaines qui viennent
la france devra aller plus loin dans le
bien-être animal et pour lutter contre
notre question de brigitte bûcher les
aliments il sera transformé trop gras
trop sucré trop salé
est-ce qu'ils sont suffisamment contrôlé
il ya des études qui montrent qu'il ya
des risques de cancer accru avec ses la
consommation importante de ces éléments
transformé qu'est ce que vous faites
pour lutter contre on a le moral à zéro
quand senti beaucoup de
l'agroalimentaire bashing il ya de la
grille bashing du foot bashing c'est
absolument réa le foot bashing mariage
mais je vais répondre très sérieusement
à cette question parce qu'elle est
fondamentale
aujourd'hui oui quand on a ses courses
on attend maintenant on a de l'obésité
de plus en plus sheila chez les jeunes
quand vous faites vos courses de chevaux
sur je suppose que ce choix de
smartphones et les yuccas et donc vous
regardez avec votre application yucca
pour savoir quel et j'en suis sûr de
savoir révélateur pour savoir quelle est
la composition du produit
il faut il faut travailler dans cette
direction il faut la transparence la
plus totale et que les françaises et les
français sachent ce qu'ils achètent
est ce qu'il ya dans ces produits de
toute façon c'est irréversible tout cela
donc il ya ceux qui veulent faire qui
veulent mettre les deux pieds sur le
frein
moi j'ai le pied sur l'accélérateur
c'est à dire parce que dans tous et dans
tous ces domaines il faut avancer
avancer avancer faire la transparence la
plus totale et donner la possibilité à
chaque acheteur chaque consommateur de
savoir ce qu'ils achètent la composition
de ce procès car pour l'instant on en
est là pour l'instant il ya des règles
il ya des débats qui sont sans cesse
dans la société
il y aura d'autres lois sur
l'alimentation qui seront faites nous
verrons bien mais chaque chose en son
temps
chaque chose en son temps d'accord alors
aurillac le virus de la peste porcine
africaine a été détecté en belgique
proche de la frontière française
est-ce qu'il faut redouter l'arrivée du
virus dans notre pays oui il faut la
redoute et en même temps j'ai
l'impression que on a tout fait pour que
ça n'arrive pas j'ai vu qu'aujourd'hui
le danemark faisait la même chose que
nous pour dessandier qui arriverait
d'allemagne qui est de
des pays de l'est par l'allemagne qu'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est que en belgique
il ya eu beaucoup de cas il ya beaucoup
de sangliers atteint par la peste
porcine africaine
je veux dire ici que la france est
indemne de cette peste porcine
aujourd'hui à leurs acquis des et je
pense que ça va durer et que
deuxièmement le mot peut faire peur mais
la peste porcine africaine qui assure
les sangliers sur les ports n'est pas
transmissible à l'homme de quelque façon
que ce soit quand même rassuré les
choses et remettre un peu de bon sens
nous avons pris des mesures
nous avons construit une barrière très
solide pour qu'ils s'engagent et puis
pas passer nous faisons un vide
sanitaire une zone blanche pour enlever
les cinglés du milieu ça a été saluée
par tout le monde les autorités belges
la commission européenne aujourd'hui pas
d'inquiétude là non et on sait pas ce
qui paraît gracieux
en tout cas nous avons fait tout ce qui
était en notre possibilité en relation
avec la filière porcine que je veux
vraiment remercier parce que c'est eux
qui sont les premiers concernés pour
faire en sorte que ça n'arrive pas sur
les deux ou trois fois en meuse dans les
ardennes tu viens en belgique bon
aujourd'hui la situation est sous
contrôle
30 % des captures de pêche qui dépendent
du président ça monte à 50% bretagne 75%
dans les hautes france qu'est ce qui est
prévu en cas de nos deals est ce qu'il
ya un accord un accord tacite un accord
cacher alors il n'y a pas d'accord caché
ce qu'a dit un accord pêcheurs c'est un
ce serait un drame
une des grandes difficultés pour les
pêcheurs si les aubry territoriales
britanniques étaient fermés aux bateaux
français
je ne partage pas les chiffres que vous
donnez puisque c'est pas à ce niveau là
c'est pas 80% mais c'est très c'est très
important
donc le président la république le
présidentiable voilà le président la
république a dit c'est pour les grands
bateaux le présent la république a dit
il n'y aura pas la pêche ne sera pas la
variable d'ajustement de du breakbeat et
michel barnier le commissaire au nom de
la commission a annoncé la même chose
pour l'instant nous sommes en discussion
demain matin j'ai réuni toute la filière
pêche d'amont en aval pour aborder pour
regarder ces sujets aujourd'hui
l'objectif c'est que nous puissions
continuer à pêcher dans les eaux
territoriales britanniques nous précise
pêcheurs et personne ne peut le garantir
aujourd'hui puisque c'est parce que tous
les jours au royaume uni des choses
changent donc c'est parce que c'est le
29 mars
on est ravi de ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que la france est prête un break
site dur avec les douaniers avec y
compris de mon ministère
nice à l'agriculture de l'alimentation
les contrôles sanitaires parce qu'elle
falloir contrôler les produits
sanitaires qui entrerait et puis nous
verrons bien ce qui se passera pour les
pêcheurs la réunion a lieu demain matin
d'accord très bien on espère éviter la
bataille navale ah oui oui absolument
absolument
dernière question à demi-nus terminé dix
ans n'est pas d'accord avec vous allez
pas me la faire tous les jours et je
vous en pensez quoi
non je crois qu'il faut arrêter la
polémique où les sujets avec les
directement à la ministre de la santé
n'a hélas pas du tout on est en phase
avec agnès buzyn nous avons fait nous
avons fait une réunion la molécule de
vin ou la molécule d'alcool est
exactement la même
simplement la viticulture française est
un patrimoine et quelque chose de
différent par rapport à d'autres
boissons
voilà je me suis déjà exprimé sur le
sujet n'y a pas de problème j'assume
tout ce que j'ai dit sans aucun problème
je suis en train de travailler avec la
filière viticole pour la faire muter
pour une sortie dudit foza total ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que la filière
viticole se bat pour la lutte contre
l'alcoolisme et l'alcoolisme est très
mauvais faut se battre pour être 58
morts tant d'autres oui et notamment
pour l'alcoolisme des jeunes mais je ne
pense pas que la solution soit supprimé
soit de supprimer l'alcool dans notre
pays des mesures pour l'étiquetage des
bruits notamment notamment sur les
femmes enceintes qui aura
vraisemblablement dans les semaines qui
viennent un autocollant sur les sur les
étiquettes indiqué comme tout groupe k
en tout cas l'objectif c'est de se dire
l'alcoolémie l'alcoolisme et dangereux
l'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
voilà très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre merci à vous mesdames la
semaine prochaine c'est françois-xavier
bellamy la tête de liste et l'aéro
européenne qui sera notre invité bonsoir
à tous
[Musique]